(crunches)
(screams)
♪ Brickleberry
- Brickleberry National Park,
Head Ranger Ethel speaking.
The park expense
reports are late.
We have those?
I'll get right on that.
I'm sorry, can you hold?
Hello, Head Ranger--
What do you mean,
the lake's on fire?
Oh my God, the answer is yes.
- It's the world's smallest
white noise machine.
- What? What about us?
- We're done, I'm not
ready to settle down.
But you can set
this to heavy rain
to mask the sound of your tears.
- I wonder if it cures bitch.
- I think my hymen
just grew back.
- It's on the house.
- Well, aren't you a sweetheart.
- Do you really
think the bartender
just gave you a free drink
because he's a sweetheart?
- Yeah, why else?
- Because your
pants are so tight
I can read the mileage
on your vagina.
- We have contact.
- Do you have to
narrate everything?
So, I just slept
with a disgusting,
asshole douche bag for nothing?
Isn't anyone gonna say anything?
- Well, normally this is
where Malloy would jump
in with something like, "Yeah,
but how's that different
"from your typical
Tuesday?" (laughs)
- No, I think it'd be more
like, "You did it for nothing?
"Usually you get
Taco Bell out of it."
- Or something like,
"Disgusting asshole?
"You mean you finally
slept with Connie?"
- Oh yeah, that's it.
- (laughs) Slut.
- Oh yeah, yuck it up.
I just banged a guy who calls
his penis the USS Enterthighs.
♪ Brickleberry